but we start tonight in South Carolina
Democratic Party is in a state of
shambles now it is 251 days until you we
the American people you will be the
ultimate jury you will render your
verdict Democrats are in the midst of a
full-blown political crisis last night's
debate was a national embarrassment the
candidates on stage frankly just made
fools of themselves they scream they
shouted they lied they complain they
whined and apparently it was amateur
hour over CBS News the moderators lost
any in all sense of any control The
Daily Beast calling it a train wreck
remember of the New York Times editorial
board comparing that to a dumpster fire
even Democratic congresswoman Debbie
Dingell referred to it as a disgrace
that's our party in the nation by the
way wrote that there were no winners
only survivors and in case you missed
all the fun he's a perfect recap of last
night's democratic debate take a look
you could honor the rules of the debate
thank you that was pretty much like that
all night but during the rare occasion
when these petulant losers were able to
say a few uninterrupted words it was
even worse we'll start with the clear
front-runner and that would be Bolshevik
Bernie Sanders last night the old Soviet
style socialists really got back to his
communist roots he didn't have a single
positive thing to say about America but
once again he goes out of his way to
praise Cuba's oppressive socialist
government you know the one where they
killed people stole their property and
put well pretty much all their citizenry
in poverty take a look what I said is
what Barack Obama said in terms of Cuba
that Cuba made progress on education yes
I think really really
to cut brock obama Sade's they made open
great progress on education making
health care that was barack obama and
when dictatorships whether it is the
Chinese or the Cubans do something good
you acknowledge that now there may have
been a few scattered booths in the
audience but Bolshevik Bernie is now the
clear torch bearer of the Democratic
radical socialist party now this is a
lifelong government employee three
houses despises capitalism hates anyone
that's successful praises communism
vilifies success and associates with
some of the most vile activists in the
United States for example known bigot
there she is Linda Sarsour national
surrogate for Bernie Sanders now she is
a despicable virulent anti-semite she
supports Sharia law praises yep Louis
Farrakhan of the Nation of Islam
well rabid anti-semite and racist blames
her negative image on the Jewish media
it's no wonder Bolshevik Bernie directs
so much vitriol towards Israel at the
debate even called Israel's government
racist and Bolshevik Bernie is a walking
talking 78 year old disaster for the
entire Democratic Party he represents
what is the ugly truth about about just
how radical how extreme this new
socialist Democratic Party has become
and now by the way the mob and the media
they are worried Democrats across the
country might be totally unelectable we
could have told you that before this all
started in other words this new shift
show take a look I was disappointed with
birdies answer on the socialism question
he had to know that was coming the
question about Cuba right he will
continue to give that answer that he
gave to you that he he'll give it he'll
give it again tonight and then he'll dig
himself a deeper hole Bernie Sanders did
not seem to me to be quite at the top of
his game tonight he just seemed a little
bit a little bit off Bernie Sanders
isn't the first time he's really gotten
roughed up a little bit and he didn't
like it I think that sort of she
admitted he looked like he had a cold
Bernie was rattler
the first time in any of these Durney
was rattle for the first time now
Democrats who are terrified of
nominating Bolshevik Bernie they're
desperately searching for Plan C D and E
choices are not good for example quid
pro quo Joe is running on fumes if he
doesn't win big in South Carolina I
think we could pretty much say his
campaign is over but so far
quid pro quo Joe has underperformed in
every single contest to date one simple
reason he is a horrific candidate and
let's forget about the baggage for a
moment let's focus on something else Joe
303 304 he lost it you've ever had a
softball he lost that to the man can
barely get out a sentence before he
loses his train of thought the fits of
anger bizarre moments agitation of
pretty troublesome and by the way he
just seems completely incapable of
recalling basic fundamental facts like
oh I'm running for president not the
Senate last night's debate we got
another example during a very bizarre
strange inexplicable rant Joe will claim
that 150 million Americans have been
killed by guns since 2007 okay let's do
the math 150 million oh that would be
half the US population
take a look a hundred and fifty million
people have been killed since 2007 when
Bernie voted to exempt the gun
manufacturers from liability more than
all the wars including Vietnam from that
point on carnage on our street alright
so quid pro quo Joe clearly not up to
the task of running for president much
less actually serving as president
that's a scary thought and you got
meanwhile billionaire Michael yes many
Mike the farmer bloomberg was supposed
to be the Democrats plan B well let's
just say it's not going very well yes
the mayor X mayor farmer expert New York
from New York delivered another horrific
debate performance during a pretty
revealing Freudian slip
Bloomberg actually boasting that he
bought the democratically controlled
house well he thinks he can buy anything
amazing take a look let's just go on the
record they talked about 40 Democrats 21
of those with
people that I spent a hundred million
dollars to help elect that all of the
New Democrats that came in put Nancy
Pelosi in charge and gave the Congress
the ability to control this president I
got that yes many Mike the farmer might
be able to buy endorsements Fund
Congressional Campaign spend hundreds of
millions of dollars
slick political ads but one thing you
can't buy is charisma or personality or
a coherent agenda that would resonate
with the American people
oh you're 95 you have cancer goodbye go
home to your family we're not gonna take
care of you we can't afford that
there's no amount of money that can
purchase a personal connection with the
voters that's why Bolshevik Bernie is
destroying Bloomberg and nearly every
single poll it is now Bernie Sanders
race to lose by the way god help us
whoever gets the nomination if they were
ever to win that's why in 251 days there
is a lot at stake